qué destaca de este discurso de lazo en
un contexto tan particular
Buenas tardes Bueno es un discurso de
rendición de cuentas que quiere hacer
énfasis obviamente en todo lo bueno y
destacar los logros sobre todo los
logros macroeconómicos le puso mucho
énfasis en el control de la inflación
por ejemplo o el crecimiento del 3%
que está por sobre el promedio de
América Latina y
destacando lo bueno lo bueno del
gobierno después de tener una una crisis
como la que estamos teniendo es un poco
el objetivo del ejecutivo no y
precisamente Con qué fuerza llega el
oficialismo las fuerzas que están ahora
en El Ejecutivo a la convocatoria de
nuevas elecciones
el oficialismo llega muy debilitado de
hecho el oficialismo no
no planea digamos poner un un candidato
o al parecer hasta ahora el presidente
no se no se postula como candidato y más
bien
se vislumbra se vislumbra Perdón una una
fuerte posibilidad de candidatos de la
oposición no O como por ejemplo el
posible candidato del correísmo
o candidatos de fuera del espectro
político tradicional entendiendo como
tradicional también la izquierda
entendida como el correísmo No sí y
precisamente en esta campaña tan corta y
tan particular Qué temas van a centrar
la atención y sobre todo las propuestas
de la oposición en un contexto de una
gran crisis de seguridad que atraviesa
el Ecuador
Sí justamente Ese es el tema el tema
central que que enfoca la atención de
todos y hasta ahora los discursos de los
posibles de los precandidatos que se van
se van pronunciando son sobre todo en
torno a violencia y seguridad entonces Y
claro el tema de pobreza educación
vivienda quedan un poco relegados
por esa por ese ese fuerte
énfasis que van a ser todos los
candidatos hacia ese